rise of Skywalker has fallen to the
bottom of the Star Wars Pack I got a bad
feeling about this
according to review aggregator Rotten
Tomatoes the ninth and final film in the
skywalker saga has officially become the
worst reviewed live-action Star Wars
film of all time edging out Star Wars
The Phantom Menace to take over the
bottom spot rise now sits at 52% on the
old tomato meter while Phantom Menace
has a score of 53% while the development
isn't exactly surprising given the
extremely mixed reaction from audiences
and critics the rise of Skywalker
it is rather shocking considering that
the highly anticipated film closed out
one of the most beloved cinematic sagas
of all time not to mention the fact that
the preceding two films in the sequel
trilogy 2015's the force awakens and
2017 s the last Jedi are both among the
top four most well reviewed of all the
Star Wars flicks by professional critics
right alongside a new hope and the
Empire Strikes Back
obviously fans feel differently about
the last Jedi but we're talking critics
only here since initially posting a
score in the high 50s rise of
Skywalker's score has slowly but surely
sunk like a stone as reviews have
continued to come in the movie which saw
the unexpected return of Emperor
Palpatine wrapped up the character arcs
of Rey Finn and Poe and served as a
final cinematic farewell to the late
Carrie Fisher should have been a movie
event for the ages instead it largely
failed to satisfy due in large part to
the seeming insistence of the filmmakers
or if certain online conspiracy theories
are to be believed
Disney a correcting course from the last
Jedi and shoehorning in egregious
amounts of fanservice rise can take
solace in the fact that it slowly rating
pales in comparison to the animated film
the Clone Wars with its miserable arty
score of 18% when it comes to the
question of what went wrong with rise
the only simple answer is it wasn't just
one thing while many fans weren't
enthralled with some of the bolder
narrative choices made by writer
director Rian Johnson in the last Jedi
Rises seeming preoccupation with undoing
many of those choices largely wasn't
seen as a great move either
then there's the return of Palpatine as
the big bad with virtually no
explanation given as to a how he
survived a tumble down a mile-long shaft
on an exploding Space Station and return
to the Jedi or
be where he's been all this time the
about-face of kylo Ren back to the side
of lights was widely considered to have
been poorly and confusingly handled and
the near exclusion of Kelly Marie Trans
Rose Tico a major character in the last
Jedi simply left a lot of critics peeved
may the force be with you
it's also been pointed out most
succinctly by the washington post jean
park that the movie's narrative
resembles nothing so much as the plots
of a video game with its over reliance
on fetch quests which ultimately proved
to be of little to no actual importance
truly in contrast to the unified if
divisive vision of Star Wars creator
George Lucas with his much reviled
prequel trilogy it took a committee
which included Lucasfilm president
Kathleen Kennedy director and co-writer
JJ Abrams co-writer Chris Terrio and
formerly attached director Colin
Trevorrow who retained a story credit to
craft a conclusion to an epic nine film
series as flat and uninspired his rise
of Skywalker fortunately though the
future of Star Wars looks pretty bright
if only because Lucasfilm and Disney
have more than one blueprint to follow
in order to get the franchise back on
track first and foremost the Disney Plus
series the Mandalorian which has totally
won over fans and critics alike and
contrast the rise of Skywalker the
series has actually earned favorable
comparisons to well-crafted well plotted
video game stories not to mention its
exploration of some of the seedy or
portions of the galaxy far far away and
it's introduction of inspired new
characters such as the suddenly
ubiquitous baby Yoda have reminded fans
how compelling Star Wars can be when
storytellers like Mandalorian creator
John Favreau are given free rein to put
their own stamp on the property second
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Marvel
Studios is of course also owned by
Disney and its decade-plus long
existence has been one long case study
on how to craft stories based on beloved
properties build and sustain interest
while indulging the muses of an entire
collective of unrelated creatives and
wrap up extended narratives with event
films that feel like events it's no
coincidence that Marvel head honcho
Kevin Feige has been tapped to produce
at least one Star Wars film in the
future or the Taika Waititi who directed
the final episode of the Mandalorians
first season and helm thor ragnarok in
the upcoming Thor love and thunder for
Marvel is aligned to also direct the
future Star Wars for
if the rumors are to be believed
hopefully the mouse house will learn the
right lessons from rise of Skywalker's
lukewarm reception from fans and critics
and looking to its most successful
subsidiary for inspiration certainly
doesn't seem like it get hurt check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]